[Music]
okay
yes
[Music]
six
[Music]
okay
i'm sorry
so
[Music]
right
out
yes
oh that's it
okay
[Music]
yes
your fault
man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
thank you so much of course
what's going on exciting time
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
oh
actually
[Music]
um
[Applause]
me
[Music]
uh
okay
uh
[Music]
good night how are you
but if you have your camera there
this is
uh
[Music]
um
oh
[Music]
uh
foreign
ah
okay
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
yes
more
um
thank
okay
yes
thank you
great
okay
mic check one two one two mic check one
two three
mic check one two
anyway
okay
okay
no matter what right i never know how
it's possible
thank you
no i'm not you know
this
spectrum
uh
yeah i hear you
sounds good
uh
thank you
okay
uh
here
i i was blown away by it frankly i mean
these are members of congress who
witnessed the events of january 6 and
you had some of them saying
i'm not convinced that they were trump
supporters uh we had one
republican member of congress say that
the the woman who tried to breach the
the house floor was uh was uh executed
by a capitol police officer uh pointing
out that uh
another another member of congress
pointing out that the whole chamber
wasn't even breached at all
so they were conflicting information
about that and to me
just an absolute whitewash and a
rewriting and
a false revisionism of what happened on
january 6 that i think is actually
critical to understanding
how the republican party is framing up
at this moment
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
and he knows that he hears it every day
he reads it
when the president puts out these
statements these false statements
continuing to try to relitigate
of the the events of of november and
january 6. and to me
to my mind it is that any
member of congress would say that than
anything other than
an assault on the capitol took place
driven by trump's supporters who were
egged on by the president those are
facts just like
it's a fact that joe biden beat donald
trump
[Music]
yeah and it looks like she'll have the
job tomorrow and there'll be some
meetings that she's engaged in to try to
talk to members of congress i noticed
just a little while ago
the republican national committee is
already raising money off of elise
stefanik's name they
it's a foregone conclusion essentially
although there are some conservatives
that aren't happy with her voting record
including your opposition to the trump
tax bill but we've seen
congresswoman stephonic really change
her stripes politically
from someone who's very skeptical of
trump and skeptical of his ideology
someone who is
all in and that's why she is almost
certainly going to be replacing this
channel
member of house leadership colonial has
begun restarting the flow of refined
products
in their pipeline this morning colonial
reported that
fuel is beginning to flow the majority
of the markets
it's a huge change and i think
particularly if if republicans take back
the house next year
to have someone that is a majority party
in leadership
at least the number three if not
um she is so young only 36 years old
she's got a very
long future potentially in the
republican party and i do think so
for her constituents you know that the
district went for president trump by
double digits
by a little bit more uh to the center
they're happy with their allegiances
with trump i think they'll be happy to
see
uh her emergence now is a true star in
the
trump republican party normal operations
uh and it's going to take some time
and there may be some hip hit thank you
like i
still we expect to see a region
by region return to northeast beginning
this weekend
and continue the next week in the
meantime
i want to update you on what our
administration is doing to accelerate
this process
to mitigate shortages and to protect you
from price counts
first relaxed rules for pipeline
operators to provide flexibility for
emergency personnel
to help manually get portions of the
pipeline up front
earlier this week secondly over the
weekend we reviewed and
worked with the company to get a portion
of the pipeline system from north
carolina and maryland
operate under manual control delivery
to deliver its existing in addition we
put in place emergency orders
that lifts hours the hours restrictions
and allow states to lift weight
restrictions
for tank truck drivers this allows those
drivers to work more and carry more fuel
in the affected regions
third the environmental protection
agency issued
a targeted 20-day waiver
of standards in several states to give
fuel suppliers
more flexibility to use available fuels
that are needed which is boost
and those last two actions are made tens
of millions of gallons permissions
administration was taken we estimate
sent enough gas to stations to fill the
tanks over five million vehicles
in the last few days fourth
as part of an effort to use every
possible me
to accelerate last night
he granted a waiver of the jones to our
fuel suppliers
this allows non-us flag vessels to
transport refined fuel
from mexico and we'll grant
additional waivers if necessary these
steps are temporary
but they will remain in place until full
service
is fully restored this is
the whole of government response
including police officers and you're
here today honoring police officers
if you're honest in your statement
what's wrong about it
um it's up to them i mean if there's a
tape i'd rather listen to the president
but a temporary situation it's up to the
conversation the next few days as i said
we expect the situation you just said
you didn't take what i said in context
so can you explain
and explain to us explain to us
listen to what i said we did do you
believe that january
6 was was an insurrection i repeat
do not try to take advantage of
consumers during this time
i'm going to work with governors the
affected states to put a stop to christ
county wherever it arises
i'm asking our federal agencies to stand
ready for private assistance
state level efforts to monitor and
address any price calculator
nobody should be using a situation for
financial gain
that's what the hackers are trying to do
that's what they were about
not us that's not who we are
and as for the people who carried out
this attack
the fbi's released details on the attack
so
others can take steps
are living in russia that's where it
came from where from russia
direct communication with moscow
imperative
responsible countries it's a decisive
action against these yeah melanie i
think this has to be a huge wake-up call
we've thought about
previous hacks in the abstract or maybe
it's government systems even election
systems
but this is about as easy to understand
as possible how easy it seems to have
been
uh how small the relatively the lift was
for these hackers
is stunning they can mean to the us
economy to people's lives
uh gas lines like we probably haven't
seen in decades price gouging concerns
uh it's taking a little while to unravel
from this hopefully we'll get on the
other side of this the president
certainly thinks it's only a temporary
blip but
it's true i think in terms of what it
says about the vulnerability of
infrastructure this is a very big deal
the majority of which is privately owned
and managed like colonial pipeline
private entities are in charge of their
own cybersecurity
you know we've seen a lot of a lot of
partisanship and a lot of partisan
sniping i see this has been a week as
president
she's been trying to talk to as many
republicans as he can
he's had a couple of meetings in the
white house with members of leadership
with rank and filers
we just haven't seen any kind of
tangible uh reaction or response that
that results in
new partnerships or our new togetherness
in any way so we'll see how this shakes
out we're seeing a lot of republican
criticism of the fact that this pipeline
disruption happened
i don't think it's the administration's
fault but obviously anytime gas prices
go up it's easy to blame a president to
share information
strengthen cyber security practices and
deploy technologies
and increase reliance against cyber
attacks
it outlines innovative ways the
government will
thrive
no she sure doesn't listen she's going
to be vocal in
in stating her beliefs including perhaps
your belief that
the election was not stolen that it's
important for people to stand up and say
it's a statement in favor of
constitutional values to say that donald
trump lost the election
he lost it legitimately to her mind
donald trump constitutes a continuing
threat to the democracy
as long as he talks about the allies in
the election and there are a lot of
republicans who believe him
they're flat wrong and they're
perpetrating and believing a lie
that's what cheney is saying she lost
her leadership post
as a result of it but she's going to be
a lot of places with a very famous last
name of course
talking about why she feels
for her to fulfill the country
with tragic results now we're seeing the
effective criminal act
well to my mind it says that there's a
civil war donald trump has wanted
there isn't much competition this was
not a close vote there's a voice vote
never in doubt doesn't mean that it's
been won personally there's a lot of
republicans talking about maybe
starting a third party
my american jobs plan includes
transformative investments
in modernizing and securing our critical
infrastructure
later this afternoon i'll be meeting
with your public consensus
to discuss ways we can unfold and
modernize the infrastructure
yeah look this is not a new conflict
obviously uh this is this is worse than
it's been in some time it's a question
of
proportionate response always flows and
then because an urgent one is in
conversation here
i think the initial response of this
administration israel is our ally
that's true in republican presidencies
as well as democratic
nevertheless i think iran's role in this
is still to be uh
figured out and i think it is the
tension in the region right now is a
very bad sign for
peace writ large um and it's going to
test joe on the international stage in a
major way
we're going to get through this as we
always do as americans we're going to do
it together
it's going to be quick god bless you all
and may god protect our troops
i thought it was so interesting how the
president responded to this because he
said he left that meeting optimistic but
then he caught himself and said i'm
generically optimistic not obviously
because
you know because he thinks that there
are areas where rank and file
republicans at least
uh can can come to the position it's
better to be talking than not
we had a dysfunctional relationship
between donald trump and democratic
leaders where nancy pelosi
the house speaker i don't think she had
a single conversation with president
trump in the last year of his presidency
that's obviously not sustainable so it's
a good sign
and republicans and democrats will come
together to even take a meeting but
of course when when the rubber meets the
legislative road that's where it's going
to happen
at all are you confident
i am confident that i've
read and reported yet accurately and
it's always my pleasure
thank you mr president wednesday's
executive order mentions the
colonial pipeline directly
private sector companies to follow the
federal government's fees this
person is good but in the face of profit
it's kind of sketchy from what
congresswoman administration they
consider
i cannot dictate that any
private companies would do a certain
thing without doing cyber security
now a lot of you are a very seasoned
encouraging recovery was debated
before i became
so that's going to be
yes
i uh had a brief conversation with him
yesterday
and i have my
intelligence community the
defense department
[Music]
i is seen thus far is that
there has not been a significant
overreaction the question is
how
how do we get to a point where they get
to a point where
there is a conduction
we haven't just spoken egyptians
thank you very much
thank you